I feel better than I deserve and I now
know that I can't just take it from this
thing that when the fever spikes you
just want to curl up in a ball and stay
there for the next six seven hours and
you can you've got a bundle up your
clothes you've got to you know start
drowning yourself in fluids you got to
take your Tylenol
and you got to get after it Chris Cuomo
is opening up about his coronavirus
symptoms and let's just say he isn't
sugarcoating it if you don't want it to
get into your lungs you got to force
yourself to breathe you got to get up
off your ass you got to walk around it
hurts you don't want to do it everything
in your body is telling you not to do it
and it's it's lying to you the CNN
anchor was diagnosed with Kovan 19 last
Tuesday I tested positive scare yes as
you might imagine but better me than you
and on Monday's episode of Cuomo
primetime he gave his viewers an update
on his health during a chat with dr.
Sanjay Gupta who have coronavirus in
most of the cases your big fear is that
it's going to get your lungs that's what
it wants it wants your lungs this thing
so this weekend I had the fever start to
go down a little bit and I started to
feel it come in to my chest so I went to
get a chest x-ray and I want you guys to
see this that's when dr. Sanjay took a
look at it and broke it all down for us
it looks pretty good maybe a little bit
of fluid buildup there but not something
that I would definitively call pneumonia
I have to tell you it is scary to have
your lungs go up there and see this
stuff and be like what what is that what
is like that smoke in there and they
tell you that's the virus it's in there
it's in you you have to fight to keep it
out and you know I'm doing fine I don't
have pneumonia but if I want to stay
that way you know I gotta have some
things fall in my favor but this isn't
the first time Chris has opened up about
his experience with the virus so yeah
I've had I've had a fever you've had a
fever but 102 103 103 Plus that wouldn't
quit and it was like somebody was
beating me like a pinata
last week the newsman who is continuing
to stream his show out of his basement
where he is still in quarantine away
from his wife and there
kids revealed just how intense his fever
was it was freaky what I lived through
last night and it may happen again
tonight doctor says may happen like five
eight times chris said that it got so
bad that he actually hallucinate 'add
and he thought he was talking to his dad
who died back in 2015 I was shivering so
much I chipped my tooth so the Sun comes
up I'm awake I was up all night was what
I'm telling you I was hallucinating I
said my dad was talking to me I was
seeing people from college people I
haven't seen it forever it was freaky
what I lived through last night and it
may happen again tonight doctor says may
happen like five eight times you know I
get it now and if you match that with
chest constriction of people can't
breathe I totally get why we're losing
so many people and why our hospitals are
so crowded and during a town hall
special about kovin 19 chris also
explains the physical toll the virus had
on his body in just a few days I've lost
13 pounds in three days now I'm a big
guy I started off at 230 pounds
my wife is feeding me like you know we
were still in the dating phase you know
so it's not like I'm not hurting
nutrition I'm eating and drinking
constantly I'm just sweating it out and
it's the sickness Chris added that his
symptoms especially his fever seemed to
get worse as the day wore on the Beast
comes at night you know as we know the
health care workers have taken to
calling the virus the Beast I understand
why my feet were has gone up a couple of
degrees and like the last 30 minutes
nights are tough and I've learned
something that I didn't know before uh
it is responsible journalism to say that
eighty percent of people who get this
statistically wind up okay meaning they
don't go to the hospital they get
through it
it is not humanly responsible though
from an ethical perspective but one
thing that the virus doesn't seem to be
affecting is Chris's sense of humor last
week when Chris popped into his brother
and the governor of New York Andrew
Cuomo's briefing they had a good hearty
laugh attack obviously the fever has
affected your mental capacity in yep
[Music]